foreign
is with us in Morristown New Jersey to
start the hour off hey Roy what's up
uh hey Dave thank you so much for taking
a call
um so I am in a bit of a pickle I am um
a 43 year old immigrant I don't have a
college education I'm just graduated
high school I was on my own for the
longest time self-employed and November
of 2019 I lost my business uh then the
pandemic hit been a divorce it and I
find myself today
four hundred and forty four thousand
dollars and that without any sex any
income and with credit card debt IRS
debt child support debt
all incurring fees and interest I'm just
not sure where to start this part
wow
I'm sorry man you've been through hell
yeah
yeah
um you're in it right now aren't you
where'd you uh yeah I sure am I where'd
you immigrate from
Israel where
Israel Israel okay yes okay what kind of
a business did you have
I owned a small business where I would
buy the uh second-hand phones iPhones
from a company called BrightStar that
did Apple's Logistics I would bring them
into my office I would separate them
test them and then refurbish them and
resell them
and why did that not work
oh it worked great for about eight years
and then I got an email from my vendor
from VyStar saying that they that
they're going to stop selling the
product because they sign an exclusive
contract with one of my competitors
so you had only one customer
one vendor correct yeah which was the
most reliable because it was basically
everything that was returned to the
Apple store or the online store would go
to BrightStar I think we do the
logistics so it was the only
um Dependable uh vendor in my market
yeah how did you come upon that
opportunity
so I've been in a cell phone business
for about uh 15 years and you know
through a lot of uh research and just uh
trade shows
uh networking I found BrightStar
okay all right
well and it worked for a while that's
interesting yeah eight years very well
so what kind of debt is the 444
so we're looking at uh 70 000 in credit
card debt we're looking at 60 000 IRS so
the IRS basically it's
capital gains tax I started investing in
2013. and because my uh I lost my job at
2019 I sold half of my portfolio in late
2019 and so what is the other 200 or 300
000 dollars
okay so we have small business loans
from the SBA how much for 100 128 okay
and then I have uh a current support
order from the judge due to my divorce
at 7 500 a month and he did that
retroactively as of like six months
before and putting me seventy thousand
dollars in debt from day one
that's back child support
correct well it wasn't really backed on
he made it retroactive yes like yeah I
wasn't I wasn't the order to pay one by
the state that he did order me the pill
and he said okay we're going back seven
months so you got a dollar amount and
not a percentage
well I got a dollar I'm gonna correct
okay but you have no job no income right
now
correct I've been trying
um applying left and right
um my issue is one of my issues is that
at 7 500 a month just for support I need
to find a job that pays me over 120 000
a year right no college education that's
a very tough ask
now what you need is a lawyer yeah uh
because most child support is based on
your income not a set fixed amount and
you need to go back before the judge and
explain and that you know say this is
what I'm making nothing and when I do
get a job you're honor I'll come back in
and we'll set the percentage by law
because every state does this by
percentages was there something did you
do something that's a that's a stout
amount or were you making just he was
making bangs a ton of money before you
lost your business no no so basically
what the judge went off was is uh my
wife's attorney was very Savvy and
convincing the judge that the capital
gains tax that I was taxed in 2019 was
250 000 and the same thing for 2020 it
was 250 000 so she convinced the judge
that somehow I was making a quarter
million dollars a year I'm not sure how
this judge didn't know the difference
between capital gains and earned income
but that's pretty much what he went off
yeah
uh your your attorney sucked and you do
need a new one and you do need to go
back in there and reset this because
it's not you have to you can't not it's
number one it doesn't work you can't pay
it you don't have any money and number
two uh you can't you can't set your
career up based on your child support
you set your child support up based on
your career and so that is not your
income and so you've got to get that
that that's a side issue the rest of
this stuff's still sitting there
um and you do need to go make some money
your best shot though at making money is
not going and getting a job it's finding
the next opportunity because you are you
have an eye for things you have an eye
for business you have an entrepreneurial
ability the only thing you screwed up in
your business model was you depended on
One Singular customer One Singular
vendor for everything and that gave them
the power to put you out of business
that's a lack of diversification you
don't want to do that you need to build
a business model out that has many many
vendors and many many customers and that
way if one of them goes sideways it
doesn't shut you down it it just is an
ouchy and so
um that's going to be your play I mean
you before you start talking about how
you're going to pay off debt uh we have
to talk about how we get income and so
you can go get a job if you want to
that's fine and then you go get before
the judge again or a different judge and
with a different attorney and get these
uh numbers reset to a reasonable amount
I'm not about people not paying child
support you need to pay child support
but you also need to pay the amount that
is a percentage of your income not some
mythical number and this is this is
pretty bizarre and uh also it feels like
you made one mistake back in 2019 and
then you borrowed some money to try to
cover that mistake and you borrowed some
more money to cover those mistakes and
so man we've got to get to where we if
we have one we fall down we dust
ourselves off we keep on on a path
moving forward we don't just keep piling
in on these mistakes man and the next
time you start your business idea you
start it with cash and you run it with
cash not with that that's right because
you're some of your credit card debt and
your SBA loan had to do with your
startup and some of it had to do with
trying to hang on after you crashed and
so to John's point so you've got to
you've got to say I'm swearing off of
debt for startup and I'm swearing off of
debt for survival so has it got you've
been through it what
what's the point when you look in the
mirror and say is bankruptcy right for
me
when do you get what's when you don't
have any other way to do it okay and
there's you know it doesn't fix this
situation because the day if he's if he
had zero debt he still has zero income
right
and the child support's not bankruptible
and neither is the IRS
so the only thing would be bankrupting
on is 70 000 worth of credit card debt
oh the SBA is bankrupt but yeah
wow sorry brother